[Music]
in the race to respond this morning more
than two dozen european countries have
started vaccinating the people most at
risk
from the coronavirus it's a crucial step
toward reopening europe to the rest of
the world
as charlie dagger reports the new
campaign puts health care workers and
the elderly
at the front of the line at a sprightly
96 years old arisely hildago became the
first person in spain to receive the
vaccination
[Applause]
applause that has echoed across europe
with good reason
in italy 29 year old nurse claudia
alvernini
called it the beginning of the end it's
the same pfizer biontech vaccine
currently distributed in the u.s
and while they may be getting a later
start europe's health system
may have an edge on actually getting
shots in arms
professor scott greer is an advisor to
the european observatory on health
systems
the problem that everybody's facing is
how to get turn a vaccine
into a vaccination how to go from having
a little vial
into doing some real good and that's
where a lot of the most difficult
politics are going to be
but it's also an area where i think we
can expect most of europe is going to be
doing better than the united states by
the end of january
in addition to pfizer pending eu
approval is moderna and oxford
astrazeneca
in all the 27 nation block has secured 2
billion
doses with the goal for inoculating all
adults
during 2021. we can start traveling
meeting our friends and family again and
have
normal holidays which we all long for
but until then we have to continue
being careful that can't come quickly
enough for hardest hit italy
coronavirus may have originated in china
but once it got a foothold in italy
it ravaged the population back in early
march
we were there when the country served as
a tragic bellwether
of what was to come in the u.s one week
ago we reported around
1700 cases that number has now
quadrupled
unimaginable the number would climb to
more than 15
million cases and 350 000 deaths across
europe the pace of mass vaccinations
will be no match to the spread of
coronavirus anytime
soon but at least the race has begun
and there is an added urgency that new
mutant virus has already become the
dominant strain here in the uk
it spreads a lot faster and it's already
been detected
in parts of europe david already
dominant charlie daggett in london thank
you charlie